Will Ripley begins our coverage
live in Kiev tonight.
And and, well,
there are a lot of things happen
You traveled north
to Ukraine's border with Belarus
Russia is once again
assembling troops tonight.
What did you find
you know, to say
there are a lot of things
happening is such an accurate re
When we had the air raid
sirens going off here
in Kiev yet again today,
when you have Russia
suffering a series of losses
on front lines
both in the east and the south.
And now to the north,
there is joint combat training
happening between Russian soldie
and Russian soldiers.
Remember, Belarus allowed Russia
to basically drive right
across their border and start th
more than nine months ago.
And tonight,
there is growing concern here in
that Belarus may actually join t
fight with their own soldiers
We just arrived
at a Ukrainian military forward
operating base
near the Belorussian border.
Here they're going to show us
the fortifications
that they put in place
to protect against a potential R
ground invasion.
A few miles away in neighboring
an ominous show of force.
Russian and Belarus, Russian tro
holding joint combat drills
like they did
earlier this year,
just before the invasion.
Are you concerned about the troo
on the Belarussian border?
We have to be concerned
because we have not friendly nei
but we have 2500 kilometers,
not friendly
borders, Belarus,
Russia, and temporarily
occupied territory.
So we have to be ready to hear
Defense Minister Wolski Reznik t
Ukraine is preparing
in case the Russians invade from
Again.
He says they urgently need more
anti-tank systems,
more advanced missile defense
have to make.
Maybe so.
We are not afraid of them,
says the Captain Dmitri.
We don't expect them to come her
But if they do, we'll be ready.
These soldiers are constantly re
ready at a moment's notice.
Do you think the Russians are
going to try to come against
this problem?
Let them try.
Before the war, he repaired
sewing machines.
Now he drives this.
How quickly
can you get guys to the trenches
if you need to do the suite?
It'll be very fast.
He says.
They started building
these trenches in early April,
reinforcing them ever since
getting ready for the Russians.
They overpowered
Ukrainian defenses
at the start of the war.
Six weeks
and thousands of deaths nationwi
Soldiers from this battalion hel
force them out.
Was there ever a point
where it was overwhelming,
where you thought,
we can't do this,
we can't fight them alone togeth
I never felt like that, says sai
Because I know there's no way ba
We have families at home.
We have children.
He says that 2500
Russian vehicles actually pass
right down this road.
Now we're driving down the same
to a bridge near the border.
Well within Russian artillery ra
When the Russians invaded
more than nine months ago,
they just drove down this road
right over this bridge.
But now the bridge has been rigg
with explosives,
and these swamplands,
which are frozen over, are full
When the first convoy
of an estimated 30,000
Russians came in February,
the Ukrainians were unprepared
and outnumbered six to one Now,
like soldiers from a century ago
they hunkered down in the trench
waiting for whatever comes down
And tonight, Aaron, here in Kiev
they're closely monitoring
a flurry of Russian military act
just in the last week, today.
The nation announced
a new foreign minister,
a new Air Force chief last week.
It was counterterrorism exercise
along with those joint combat
drills with the Russians,
not to mention the snap
military inspections.
All of it
raising alarm bells
and crucially diverting resource
potentially from the east,
from the south to the north.
Is this an attempt by Russia
to try to distract Ukraine
while they focus on other areas?
Or could this be yet another dan
facing this democracy under sieg